I'm sure people talked about this before
many times too because you know UFC you
have to wear the Reebok uniforms Scott
Coker said that he doesn't know how the
UFC can legally force the fighters to
wear since they're independent
contractors yeah he actually said this
on the front of the kid when I had him
on there last time came on he said
listen they're independent contractors
he found the latest episode of MMA now
shout out to Ariel honey how they're
forced to wear uniforms does day still
balcony I should be against the labor
laws or something because you have to
wear the sponsor you have to wear a
certain uniform when you fight to me
they should be contractually positioned
to get whatever sponsor they want if
Ryan Bayer went out and made million
dollars and SWAT ship good for you
yeah that's why Bellator is you know
doing well I agree I just don't think
anyone has the balls no stand up to the
UFC say this ain't right we talked about
to wear blue in the face until the
fighters I should do something bad I
probably stop talking about it
but Scott coke is right now they're
independent contractors can't force me
wear something because an unemployed old
Chinese lady for good luck she threw
coins into the engine of a plane
oh well good work to us we were going to
have a very rookie freak I always threw
be changing too into the terrain in GA
the best of rope the earth
I'm so smart welcome back to the fighter
in the key generated version exactly
what happened bro ah silly old [ __ ] so
on going through the chat engine
sometimes for good rock I feel bricks
into it we're gonna have the best
luckiest fright ever if yeah I got a
lock hey what's wrong is crazy [ __ ] but
how to say fly run gg gg and you know
what happened I was like Good Morning
America I said delay the flight like six
hours a slap a [ __ ]
oh yeah with you that looked like a
goddamn puddle of water in the middle of
a mall why the [ __ ] does that look like
a lucky fountain what's wrong with you
lady
Oh
longest standing traditions we always
thought say a pocket move changing there
is 7 billion dollar plane engine so
smart of us and so what do we do and why
we do you know what we do I do a nickel
a dime a quarter a vvd centerpieces yeah
I think the visi cent piece is the one
that blew up the engine she the worst
lady ever god she's flying out of China
away
I wish us all the best of luck katenka
thank me cloud of oil fiction sometimes
I shoot a gun at the pilots hand for
good luck while he frying the pain good
luck on our landing we're going to need
it it's just the worst
so what [ __ ] customer ever fly would
tell me nine doors sometimes I throw
change into the front of the engine it
comes back as in the back in paper form
the engine is like a Coinstar machine
you throw the change in the front a
little piece of paper come out in the
back tell you how much you can turn
anything just to receive for her oh yeah
oh I am like I just lost my entire Asian
fan base today which was chin or your
friend I'm pretty sure worn out sure yes
that is my Asian fan he's not offended I
think you text me yeah and then I told
my man's like uni go over and [ __ ]
meet this dude and in he types he's like
dude he's like a young Hugh Hefner like
that yes a supplement world and he's
like a [ __ ] that's exactly what he is
man like this dude's needed no for me
like you live such a crazy life like
last night let's just this is Aubrey
Marcus last night yesterday mean already
had a nice fine work out what Jesus
after them who knows I some fun weird
[ __ ] someone had a great meal went to
dinner it's awful with Gerard Butler yep
that's all right randomly right but
which slides into your DM
yeah with a [ __ ] 300 mean yeah
goes hey it's Jerry Butler you know the
300 guy did he know he's like he did it
pretty good
oh I know I know you are man ha i watch
a movie 25 times when I'm feeling sorry
for myself when I'm lying in bed and I
want to [ __ ] stop being a [ __ ] I
turn on your movie like I get it I know
you are the hall just so you know it's
me it's a him just no makeup going this
is far too uh no bro you don't have to
keep yeah you have a blue checkmark
ninja and I got a catfish yeah so he
just reached out was like let's grab a
cup of coffee yeah you know he got onto
one of my podcasts and it just really
resonated with some of the stuff that he
was interested in and something like the
spiritual consciousness concepts he just
hit the right podcast for him at the
right time and yeah and listen to that
and then started listening to some more
and just escalated my DM that was weird
cuz I was taking a [ __ ] just kind of
scrolling through looking for honey's
didn't see any honey I never seen any
honey's on there just [ __ ] [ __ ]
and Gerard Butler like that's the man's
was balloon to another actually I have a
weird pouch balloons and then fighters
taking sponsor a strategy job now it's
I'm doing so good that is not a good
resource for me I leave that to the
sopranos water man yeah but yeah man it
was really surreal is that movie like a
of all significant movies I think like
Braveheart Avatar 300 there's like a
couple that like made a difference
against like an impact and that was one
so it was cool he's a cool dude great
single Adam yeah he's like a guy's guy
yeah his accent is and he wasn't he
wasn't trying to be more than he was
like he's kind of self-effacing and
funny and like you know doesn't try to
pretend that he's super awesome or
anything yeah show-off he's just he's
four he's real which was though